[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT TAI: All right.
Thank you everyone for joining.
It's, I think, the second
to last session of the day.
It's after 5:00, so hopefully
we'll make it worth your while.
So my name is Matt.
I'm a product manager at
Google Cloud Platform.
Today, I'm going to talk about
accelerating investor insight
with commercial data on GCP.
So as an investor, you
likely need to make decisions
with facts and not feelings.
You have data you know you
need to get insights from
to ultimately make money.
And that's why we're all here.
So as an investor,
I need to discover
untapped opportunities,
understand behavior, what's
going on at the regional
and also the macro level,
and also anticipate
future trends.
Now, I need to do
all of these things,
but here are my challenges.
Commercial data lives in all
sorts of different silos,
and each one of them
has a proprietary way
of just serving data to you.
So either you connect
to an API or you
connect to an FTP or an
SFTP if you're super fancy,
or someone will ship
you a hard drive.
All of these things you've got
to plug into your own system
and figure out what you're
going to do with it.
And you spend a lot
more effort figuring out
how to unpack that than actually
analyzing the data itself.
So ultimately, which are yoy?
Are you an investor or
are you a data plumber?
So my personal philosophy is
it shouldn't be this hard.
How can Cloud help?
Just to summarize,
Google Cloud Platform
is building a data marketplace.
We are hosting commercial
data on Google Cloud Platform,
simplifying distribution.
So if you have data in
any of these formats,
we are targeting specific
Google Cloud Products
you distribute them through.
In terms of access, they
are all authenticated
through one single mechanism.
So if you work with five
different data providers,
you're not authenticating
five different times
using OAuth2 or passwords
or special HTP headers.
If you're on Cloud
Platform, you use Cloud IAM.
It's the same authentication
mechanism you're already
using as a Cloud user.
The idea here is you can log
in once and access all of them
all at the same place.
And once it's accessible in the
same place, it's ready for use
by your analysts.
You can use SQL directly
for data in BigQuery.
You can use BigQuery itself.
You can export to
Microsoft Excel.
You can pull data
from Google Sheets.
For the technical
members in the audience,
you can also use
JDBC/ODBC connectors.
If you want to throw
a biz layer on top,
BigQuery works out of the box
with Data Studio, Tableau,
Click, all those
partners up there.
Let's say you have
data scientists.
Now you can work with data from
BigQuery Google Cloud Storage.
We have a product
called Cloud Data Lab,
which is a Jupyter notebook.
If you're familiar with
scientific or numerical
computing in a Python
library called Pandas,
we have a product for that.
If you want to start
exploring machine learning
with TensorFlow,
reads from BigQuery
and also Google Cloud
Storage-- ready to go.
And if you have a data
engineering team, great.
You can work with BigQuery
Google Cloud Storage and also
Cloud Pub/Sub.
Cloud Pub/Sub is our
streaming messaging product.
From there, you can process
it using data PROC if you're
familiar with Hadoop
and SPARC, or you
can use Cloud Data Flow, which
unifies both batch and stream
processing.
Why are we doing all of this?
We want to do this to
accelerate your time to insight.
So today, we have a few launch
partners who will be coming up,
talking about how they are
delivering data specifically
to address problems in the
financial services space.
And I'd like to invite up
Al Chang, CTO from Xignite.
AL CHANG: Thank you, Matt.
So I'm Al Chang,
CTO for Xignite.
And I want to thank Matt
for inviting us here
to speak at the session.
But more importantly,
I wanted to thank Matt
for reaching out to
us late last year
and really being
instrumental in getting us up
to speed on BigQuery in
such a short amount of time.
So in the next few minutes,
what I'd like to do
is at least give you a little
background on who we are,
Xignite, what we
do, how BigQuery
plays into our offerings,
and end with a short demo.
Xignite delivers
financial market data
over the cloud via REST APIs.
We've been at this for
close to 10 years now
and we have about
1,000 customers.
We're serving about 1
trillion requests per year.
It's not Google scale,
but for us, it's
pretty big for a
45 person company.
So where we play is
basically-- we're
very strong in
the fintech space.
These are the guys
who are trying
to disrupt the traditional
financial services industry.
Our customers include the
largest robo advisors.
You've probably heard of
these names like Wealth Front,
Betterment, Personal Capital.
These are our customers.
These are the guys
who are basically
looking at financial advisors
who are hand-picking stocks
and managing your money,
and they're automating it.
And by the way, if you've
seen the news these days,
ETS are outperforming
most active funds.
And these guys, the
robo advisers, they
can charge a
fraction of the cost
because they have a
much lower cost basis.
We have some of the most
popular mobile brokers
like Robin Hood, who's
making a name for themselves
by offering $0
commission trades.
We have some of the fastest
growing online brokers
like Motif--
Motif Investment.
These guys define themes like
sustainability, fair trade,
and they will help
you invest your money
in the stocks and security
that align with those motifs.
They also let the community
define their own motifs
so they can also share.
So it's a very interesting
social meets finance
kind of a thing.
And StockTwits-- this is an
example of one of the biggest
social finance platforms.
These are the guys that
invented the cash tag.
So the point I'm
trying to make here
is that these are
examples of startups
that had this great
idea for financial help,
and now all they really need
is the market data to power it.
And so it should be
pretty simple and it is.
So if you go to the traditional
providers-- the Thomson
Reuters, the
Bloombergs, the IDCs,
you first pay a
hefty licensing fee.
Then you start to
build your data feed
handlers against legacy
proprietary protocols built
in the 70s.
You put your servers out
in colocations in New York
and Chicago to be closer to
the exchanges and [INAUDIBLE]
plants.
You've got to build out
your own production database
infrastructure to store
the data that you actually
have to pull down.
And how you build this
service infrastructure
that actually serves the
data out to your applications
just so your iPhone app can show
the current price of Google.
We think that's kind of crazy,
especially because all of this
is not a differentiator
for these companies.
If you're a robo
advisor, if you're
doing a social media platform,
you just need the data.
You don't want to spend that
much time and money doing
something that's
really a commodity.
So this is where
Xignite comes in.
We offer what we refer to as a
zero footprint market data API.
So basically what that means is
zero production infrastructure
to get financial market
data into your route.
We have REST APIs, which
is basically the same thing
as typing a URL into a browser.
That's how easy it is.
We return data in XML or
JSON, which any application
developer can easily bring into
a mobile app or their websites.
We offer data across all asset
classes, currencies, metals,
commodities, equities,
options, indices.
We have real-time
data, historical data,
company fundamentals--
basically everything
you need for a
financial application.
In addition to these
request response APIs,
we also have other
ways to get the data.
We can stream the data
directly to your device.
We have the ability to let you
define market conditions that
notify you when it occurs.
Maybe your favorite stock
hits a certain threshold.
You want email or such.
We have HTML 5 widgets that
are predefined, prepackaged,
and customizable, which you
can directly put into your app.
Once again, zero footprint-- you
don't have to host a widgets.
We host them.
We manage the checking of all
the conditions on our side.
Cloud streaming-- same thine.
All the infrastructure
is on our side
so you don't have to put
anything on your side.
So which brings us
to why am I here?
Well, we do have one
area which we have,
quite honestly, a very
suboptimal solution for,
which is basically our customers
who want to do analytics.
They have certain
algorithms to try
to predict the way
the market's going
to go with different data.
They want to do backtesting
based on the historicals
to get a feel for how
accurate their stuff would
have happened in the past.
So today, we have
the opportunity
to download bulk CSVs, which
people still use today.
We have historical options
data, index data, equities data.
We even have all the
trades and quotes
for US exchange for
the past 10 years.
That's a ton of data, which is
just terabytes and terabytes
of data-- well, I
forget I'm at Google--
it's only terabytes of data.
It's not petabytes of data.
But still, that's a
ton of time, which
quite honestly, the
easy way to get the data
is sort of what
Matt referred to--
it's actually getting a
hard disk with the data
and shipped it to them.
It's much faster than trying
to bring it over the internet.
So what I'd like to
do now is show you
what we've been working on.
It's basically taking
our historical data
and bringing it into Big
Query and making it available
directly from the
Google Cloud Platform.
Can we switch the screens?
OK.
So this first screen here is
basically Google BigQuery.
We have tables of historical
data for currencies, equities,
indexes, and metals.
And the quick very basic
demo-- but hopefully this
will get the point
across that I'd
like to show you-- is,
let's say that you've
heard that gold is a great
hedge against the stock market.
If the market's going down,
gold goes up and vice versa.
So let's do it.
Let's just test that out.
What I have here on my laptop
is basically Our Studio--
very common tool.
You can use any tool you want--
just giving you an example--
where I'm essentially
just making
a script that makes a
direct SQL call to BigQuery
to pull the historical time
series data for gold for--
its kind of funny.
Originally in my
demo was the S&P 500.
But since Thani's here, I just
changed it five minutes ago
to pull the Dow Jones
Industrial Average.
[LAUGHING]
For the Dow Jones Industrial
Average and for a gold mining
stock--
Newport Mining.
So let's really do a query,
check the correlations,
and plot the data.
So you run this thing.
And up pops the quick graph.
It shows you-- the red
line, I believe is gold,
green line is the Dow
Jones, and the blue line
is Newport Mining.
So even visually,
you can see there's
a very interesting correlation,
but you can actually
get the actual values as well--
a correlation of 0.65
with Newport Mining
and a negative 0.45 with the
Dow Jones Industrial Average.
So you get a feel for not just
is it negative and positive,
but even how much.
Now, really simple
example, right?
But the point here is that
I never had to download CSV.
I never had to put
in my own database.
I never had to
maintain that solution.
If I wanted to, I
could even go back here
and say, well, let me just
check against the S&P 500.
Take a different one, run it.
Where's my run?
There it is.
Here it is.
And you can do this
over and over again.
So now let's pull
some more data.
I want to try it out.
It's all out there in the cloud.
So can we switch back
to the presentation?
So just in closing, I just want
to share with you that today,
we do have sample
data up there for you
to try and get a feel
for how easy it is.
And we have obviously a lot
more data that's in our sample,
but this is at least
an example to give you
a flavor for how easy it is.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT TAI: All right.
Thank you, Al.
So I don't know if this
was clear earlier--
every provider we
have on stage today
we've asked to provide a sample.
If you're interested
in licensing
their commercial data, you
work with them directly.
So next up, I'd like to
introduce Jeremy Sicklick,
CEO of HouseCanary.
JEREMY SICKLICK: Great.
Thank you, Matt.
Thank you, everyone.
So today we're going
to talk a little bit
about residential real estate.
Residential real estate in the
United States is a $30 trillion
market.
It's the largest asset
class in the United States
or the world for that matter.
And whether you're a major hedge
fund, you're a big investor,
you're a big lender, or
even just a homeowner,
we all struggle with two
fundamental questions.
Number one, what is the
value of this property?
And number two, is the
price going to go up
or is it going to go down?
And at HouseCanary,
that's what we've
been focused on
solving and providing
to a number of sophisticated
investors and lenders
over the last couple of
years using massive data
sets and a lot of machine
learning that I know
is being talked about a lot.
And we're excited to
put a couple of parts
of our platform on the
Google Cloud platform today.
So let's talk about the state
of affairs in real estate today.
It's massively fragmented.
In essence, you have
$120 million properties
in the United States
every property
is its own unique snowflake.
They're all different.
And underlying that, the
data is super fragmented.
You've got 3,000 or 3,200
different county assessors
and public recorders, 750
different multiple listing
services, a number
of other sources.
The problem is is
every one of those data
sources are all different.
There's no common
data standards.
So the information that
you get from one never
aligns with the next.
The definitions of what it
means are all different.
And in many cases, it's
all still paper-based.
That's what's slowing down
the process of buying homes,
lending on them.
So what we've been
really focused on
is really bringing this
information together
about this massive asset class,
bringing in the 21st century,
and largely indexing
all the details
about every home,
every mortgage,
and every neighborhood.
And when you do that,
there's three things
that this really
starts to enable.
Number one, we can
get deeply detailed.
Today, if you read
the newspaper,
it'll come out that Kay Schiller
says that Chicago is up by 4%.
But what does that mean
about my local area?
For us, we're now providing
that level of detail
by every 381 US metropolitan
areas, 18,000 zip codes--
every zip code where there's a
population of 1,000 or more--
and now blocks,
three million blocks.
How are prices changing--
getting down to the details.
The second area is
really being predictive.
Past is not prologue
for the future.
I think we've all realized
that through what's
happened in the
markets over time.
And the idea is to
bring the history
but then also use
machine learning
and predictive analytics
to really forecast
what's going to happen
in the markets using data
that no single human
could ever figure out.
It's too complicated
at this point.
And finally just bringing
the amount of data
that you can bear and
building highly accurate
values for 90 million
homes that are updated
monthly, rental values
for 60 million homes,
given how large single
family rental is now
as an asset class.
So to make this real, what we
wanted to do and what we did--
it was a really easy
process for us--
is we loaded about a billion
data points from HouseCanary,
from our platform,
into BigQuery.
And then we basically
put on top Tableau.
So it's just fully stock
what we're going to show--
just pulling some examples out.
So given that we're
in San Francisco,
I wanted to start with
an example around prices.
What's happened with
prices in San Francisco
over the last year?
Most people would say, well,
prices changed by about 9%
right in this area.
But if you look at
it, on the low end,
you've got Pacific
Heights in red
that basically grew by 7.1%.
You've got the Mission
a couple of miles
away at a zip code level
that grew at 13.6%.
And if you go out to the East
Bay and parts of Oakland,
it's even grown by a
lot more than that.
But now, the idea is to not
only deal at the zip code level,
but actually to then
dig in block by block.
That's where
investments are made.
That's where money
is made and lost.
And so for us, dealing
now at the block level,
we dig into these zip codes
and provide this information.
There's these nice
parent-child relationships
that we've linked
everything together
so I can look at multiple
levels and now we're
down at the block level,
looking into the future.
And basically, I
can see that there's
parts of San Francisco
that are likely to decline
and are declining right
now at a block level--
parts of the Presidio.
And you go a few miles away,
and prices are going up--
double digits.
And for us, that's the
dispersion of returns,
getting down to
the segmentation.
That's where the
information's really available
and the opportunities for making
better investment and lending
decisions.
So now, let's actually
think about how
we might actually take that one
more level down to properties.
For HouseCanary, what
we've done and what
we've put up into BigQuery
and GCP is basically
for every single property,
we have a unique identifier
linked to the address, linked
to the latitude and longitude.
So now you can start actually
looking at every property,
not only against
HouseCanary data,
but linking it to
your own databases,
linking it out to
other data sets
that we'll talk about,
where latitude and longitude
and joins are really important.
And you can start
identifying opportunities.
In this case, we just
pulled up two properties
sold at about the same
time, look very similar.
What's going to happen
over the next year?
One's likely to
have price declines,
the other is likely to
have price increases.
But this isn't really all about
doing this with two properties.
This is about lots
of properties.
And so whether you're a major
lender, a major investor,
a retailer, this is
where the use case really
comes in for how to use
this kind of information.
So maybe I'm a major lender
and I'm thinking about--
I hold loans in the
San Francisco area.
For those loans
that I have, which
ones are going to
see increases, which
ones are going to see declines?
Where is there opportunity?
Where is there risk?
How do I change my
lending practices?
How do I manage
risk ahead of time?
I might also be an investor
that's not comparing
to my current portfolio.
But I might be looking for
new investment opportunities,
and you can start
to think about how
I start to look at
investment opportunities that
may be coming up through
different bankruptcies,
through MLS, linking
it to our evaluations,
our rental analytics
if I'm looking to rent,
and thinking about where
prices are starting
to increase or decrease.
Many, many opportunities
to basically search--
find opportunities.
So on GCP, we've
basically loaded--
as I mentioned--
about a billion data
points to begin off
of our platform.
There's a lot more where
this came from, and based
on interest and where the
interest and everybody guides
us, we'll continue to add more.
But really what
we've done and what
we started with was basically
adding first home price
indices--
home price indices for
all US metro areas,
18,000 zip codes that cover
about 95% of the US population,
and 3 million blocks.
And for each of
those, we've basically
provided historical monthly
updates for the last 40 years.
So you can see about three
economic cycles and forecasts.
We've also included our
valuations that are third-party
reviewed and ranked
as the most accurate
in the market for
90 million homes.
And then finally,
our rental values
on 60 million
homes that are used
by some of the big
household names
in the big institutional
investors, who have gone out,
bought a lot of real
estate, set rents.
And all of these are updated
monthly at this time.
So as Matt talked about, where
we see the real opportunity
is some of those heat maps
and digging in, and starting
to join and analyze.
It used to take us
months to really do this
with whole teams of analysts.
And I was helping buy
a lot of properties
out of the Lehman crisis
and out of the downturn.
And now, it takes
a person a couple
of minutes to really
start joining, analyzing,
identifying opportunities,
identifying risk.
And for us, that's what's
exciting about this,
is the ability to just
make better decisions much,
much faster than ever before.
And so with that,
here's the URL.
You can go try it out.
And we'd love to get your input.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT TAI: All right.
Thank you, Jeremy.
Next up, I'd like to invite
Thani Sokka from Dow Jones
to talk about his product.
THANI SOKKA: Thanks, Matt,
and thanks for having us here
and talk about Dow Jones and
the type of content and data
that we have and how financial
firms and investors are
leveraging news content to
help accelerate their insights.
So the data landscape
is changing quite a bit.
I think everybody knows that.
We've seen it quite a
bit at the conference
as well over the
last couple of days.
More and more companies are
putting a heavy investment
into big data, and they
realize that in order
to really stay relevant in
the future in coming years,
they need to evaluate
how they can really
leverage big data in a way
that can actually give them
a competitive advantage and
so forth, and stay relevant
in their respective
lines of business.
And there's a great
opportunity for us
now with the accessibility
and availability
of a lot of these
new technologies--
a lot of the
technologies that we've
heard over the
past couple of days
at Google, a lot of the
open source technologies
around big data, what the cloud
computing capacity that we now
have available to us
through the Cloud and so on.
And so now,
organizations are really
looking at leveraging
that technology,
leveraging the
content data they have
in order to be able to
really drive innovation
within their organizations.
They're trying to move up
this stack from just data
information to automating things
like knowledge and wisdom.
You hear this all
the time in terms
of what people are
trying to do with things
like machine learning and
artificial intelligence.
And so really,
companies are trying
to move passed information.
Information is no longer
enough to really stay ahead.
People really need
actionable intelligence
that's very relevant to their
use case, that's accessible,
that's also customizable for
their particular business case.
And this is where we
feel Dow Jones can really
help address a lot
of those challenges
and really help customers
and investors like yourselves
and financial firms like
yourselves take advantage
of the premium news content.
Dow Jones has been creating
news around economics,
around finance, around
businesses, and so forth.
That's our bread and butter.
We've been doing it
for over 125 years.
We are the Wall Street
Journal, we are Market Watch,
we are Barrons, we
are Financial News.
So we have a wealth of content.
And not only that, we also
have a very rich taxonomy.
So we have a robust
data strategy team
that actually curates
and updates the taxonomy
that we apply on top of our
content, which makes now
our content even more valuable
in terms of how you might be
able to leverage it within
your firm to deliver insights
around your
particular use cases.
We have over 30,000
sources of content.
So beyond just the
content that we create,
we actually ingest all
sorts of other publications,
premium news across the globe.
And we actually then apply
this taxonomy on top of it
in over 28 different languages.
We have over 19.5 million public
and private companies that
are encoded in this taxonomy.
We have over 1,500
new subjects that
are encoded in this
taxonomy, over 2,400 regions,
and we have over 1.2
billion documents
and growing in our archive.
So it's a wealth of
content that now people
are starting to
leverage in terms
of whether it's quant
firms, whether it's
wealth managers, whether
it's financial advisors--
in terms of being able
to take that and build
predictive models now
that can help drive
how they do their investments.
So we're very excited to do a
little soft launch of Dow Jones
DNA.
DNA stands for Data
News and Analytics.
It's a new platform that we've
developed completely on Google.
It's leveraging a lot
of Google's big data
technologies-- a
lot of the stuff
that Matt talked about earlier.
We're leveraging Dataflow
and Dataproc and Google Cloud
Storage and BigQuery to
make our wealth of content
now available to customers in a
much more accessible way, that
can really help them innovate
and push the envelope in terms
of how they could leverage
content within their business.
We have three main ways of being
able to access this content.
We have what's called
Snapshots, to be
able to get large archives.
In the past, when customers
came to us and said,
hey, we'd like to get a year's
worth of your news archive,
it would take us
weeks to deliver it,
and we'd deliver it
via FTP and CSV files.
And it was really
difficult for a customer
to be able to really
take advantage of that.
Now, with things
like Google Cloud,
we can deliver a 30-year
archive, a 100-year archive,
in literally an hour--
30 minutes to an hour.
So it's really changing the way
customers can take advantage
of our content, whether
it's to do backtesting
to build predictive models,
whether it's to leverage
or to do specific research
around very specific use cases,
and so on.
Another way we're
delivering this
is through what
we're calling Stream.
We're actually using
Google Cloud Pub/Sub
to be able to deliver our
news content in near real time
to customers.
So imagine now
you're going to be
able to go in, leverage a
30-year archive of news,
build a predictive
model, and then apply
that predictive model
now on a stream,
and now essentially delivering
to you real time insights that
actually is actionable
that you can actually
take and start automating
within your organization.
And then we also have
a rich set of APIs
that we're building out on
top of the cloud as well,
to be able to do much more
of the request response
type of use cases, where you
might want specific data.
Because we also have a
wealth of company data,
for example, and so forth.
So you may want to
understand what's
going on with a specific company
in terms of their profile
and you may want to correlate
that with news content
and so forth.
We have search APIs as
well to really dive deeper
into our news content
if you're looking
for very specific
pieces of information.
And we're building a
very accessible ecosystem
around this as well
to make it easier
for customers to be able to
leverage this new platform.
We're launching a
new developer portal,
we're building out a customer
solutions engineering
team ourselves, and we're
really building on our partner
ecosystem with
partners like Google
in terms of making our data
more available to our customers.
And these are some of the
very cool things that people
are starting to do now
with this new platform
and with this new accessibility
to premium news content.
Internally, we had
a little code-athon,
and literally in
a matter of days,
we were able to build
these cool little assets.
We were actually leveraging
Google's natural language
processing API on
top of this platform
to do things like geo encoding
and sentiment analysis
and so forth on top of the data.
We were doing things--
leveraging our streams
to show real time
trending topics, trending
companies, trending sectors,
things of that nature that
you could start doing.
And then we also built
out a little demo
to show where you
can type in a company
and you can see the news
volume about that company
over a timeline.
And all of this
now is very easy,
even for you guys
to do internally
within your business.
And these are some
of the other things
that people are, for example,
leveraging our content for.
Imagine, being able
to go in-- again,
because we have a
very robust taxonomy--
to be able to quickly understand
the impact of various trade
sanctions across the globe.
So basically searching
through our taxonomy that
talks about compliance and
embargo and sanctions-- you
don't have to be an
expert in these things.
You can actually
leverage our taxonomy
and build on top of that.
Imagine being able to
understand the effect of China's
economic slowdown
across the globe.
Again, you can mine our content
for key terms, keywords,
across our taxonomy in terms of
looking for economic slowdown,
creating a heat map
around that type of stuff,
and understanding,
whoa, there seems
to be some really
hot areas in terms
of economic impact
of potentially
the Chinese economic slowdown.
Imagine being able
to track vaccination
trends across the globe
with our news content,
and how does that impact,
for example, investments
in the pharma industry?
Oh, we see the spread of Zika
go across these other regions.
Do we need to invest
in vaccinations there?
Are pharma investing in
vaccinations in those kind
of areas, and so forth?
So this is just the
tip of the iceberg.
You can imagine a
lot of different ways
that you could
leverage this news
content to really drive how
you guys are doing investment.
And that's really the
power of this platform
and what premium news can
really do for your business.
So we love people to
come in and try it out.
We have a sample data set
that's out there in BigQuery.
We always have a much more
robust data set than that
if you actually license
our entire content.
But we have a nice
little snippet
here that you can play with.
It's actually Brexit data or
related to Brexit in a way,
because we have all of
our news that we created,
the days up to the Brexit
and a few days after.
So you can start digging
in and seeing and analyzing
the impact of the Brexit
was across the globe.
And then we also have
a nice landing page
if you guys want to go and learn
more about our DNA platform,
learn more about our
content, learn more
about what other customers
are doing with leveraging
this new platform.
So we're excited to see
customers leverage premium
news in different ways than
the ability to in prior times.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT TAI: OK, great.
Thank you, Thani.
So next up we actually
have Accuweather.
I wasn't sure if they would
be able to make it this time,
but today we have
Rosemary joining
from Accuweather,
who will actually
be covering her own slides.
ROSEMARY RADICH: Thank you.
All right.
OK.
So how many of you,
when you're meeting
a stranger for the
first time, you
have to try to
think of something
to talk to them about?
Well, usually one of the
first things you talk about
is either television
or the weather,
because weather affects so
much of our everyday lives.
It affects how
many steps we take,
it affects what music we
listen to, it affects--
and of course,
most importantly--
what consumers buy, which
is what investors really
care about.
But there are some
challenges in order
to predict human behavior.
It requires a large
amount of data
and a large amount
of technology.
And we know the environment has
a strong impact on consumers,
but again, predicting human
behavior is very difficult.
I'm a sociologist by
training, and we usually say,
if it was easy, it
would be rocket science.
So every piece of
information you
have to help you predict to
what consumers are going to do
will help you
improve your model.
So the environment has a
huge impact on consumers
and most importantly, weather
has an effect as well.
So our solution--
we want to make sure
that you have access to
highly accurate and reliable
historical weather data.
So if you have bad
data coming in,
no matter how good
your modeling is,
how advanced your machine
learning techniques are,
if the data behind it
is bad, then the output
is going to be bad as well.
We've had several of our
clients come to us saying, oh,
we heard about this
other data source.
The website looked great and
we did a little bit of digging,
and we found out it was
some guy working out
of his mom's basement
playing X-Box half the time.
So you want to make sure
you do your due diligence
when you're looking for
these data sources to ingest.
So having a good source like
Google with reliable partners
is very important.
And so having this
weather information
allows you to unlock these
aspects of human behavior
and to uncover new insights.
So keeping this short and sweet,
if you want to try our dataset,
here is the link.
We have minimum, maximum,
temperature, precipitation,
and snow fall.
So it's a really small
subsection of the vast amount
of data that we have.
It's just one year of
data but we actually
have highly granular data
going all the way back to 1951.
We have hundreds of
different metrics,
including RealFeel,
where you can
see the impact that
temperature has on consumers.
So we have a large
amount of data.
So if you're interested in
more information for what
we have in terms of
spatial, temporal,
granularity, and
additional weather metrics,
feel free to come
talk to me later.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT TAI: So thank
you, Accuweather.
They're just getting
started in the program.
The sample is just a very small
snippet of what they offer.
We'll be working with them to
develop a more comprehensive
offering in the near future.
Next off, I also was
surprised that we
were able to have this
speaker from Remine here.
So we'll have
Jonathan from Remine
covering his own slides as well.
JONATHAN SPINETTO: Hi.
Good evening, guys.
I'm Jonathan Spinetto with
Remine, and what we focus on
is predictive scale intelligence
around SFR real estate.
So what we do is we take
a look at all the data.
Like Jeremy mentioned
earlier, it is a lot.
Over 3,200 assessors
nationwide, a multitude
of different variables.
And we combine it with
transactional property data
and we also combine it
with consumer intelligence.
So bringing and attributes
such as month and year of birth
and other individual
household level demographic
attributes to understand
when a house will
be going up for sale.
So as a realtor, a
mortgage professional,
or other type of
industry, understanding
when those homes will be
selling is what we focus on.
And like we talk about, trying
to obtain that 360-degree view
is important.
So my background is actually
full-time in real estate.
So I've been a licensed agent
since I was 18 years old.
Myself and my other
business partner,
we participated in over 6,000
residential transactions
nationwide-- one transaction
at a time, working with banks
or working with other parties.
And it really gives
you an insight
to understand what goes
on at that level, what
is in the mindset, where are
there certain life events
and life actions that
we can break down
these activities into
and understanding equity,
understanding
length of ownership.
Because usually what you
hear is the statistic
that the National
Association of Realtors
puts out that a home
sells every seven years.
Well, let's get more
granular with that
and let's understand
how we can figure out
where that information is
going to come into play.
So what we do is we look at a
classification of understanding
that sale in a si-month,
12-month, 18-month,
and a 24-month-plus frame.
So by bringing in all
of this data together,
we're able to bring
this data, now
available on the Google Cloud
as a commercial data set--
and one of the things
that we do have up there
is a snippet from our data.
It's in Alaska, in
Anchorage, where
we have that classification of
understanding these sales up
there.
So take a look.
Try it out.
Reach out to us.
We're happy to discuss
more about what
we have around that predictive
sale and other attributes
across the United
States for SFR,
and we're happy to be
working with Google on this.
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT TAI: OK, great.
Thank you, Jonathan.
And so just to wrap this
up, we had a great showcase
of launch partners
here who really
saw where BigQuery could go, and
pretty much jumped in with us.
Why are we doing all of this?
We are accelerating
your time to insight
by doing all of these things--
free hosting the data on GCP,
simplifying distribution,
simplifying access,
and making it
accessible for not just
analysts, but data scientists
and data engineers as well.
You can learn more at
cloud.google.com/commercial
datasets.
On there you will see a listing
of all five of our partners
today, links to
their sample data
sets as well as how to
contact them for licensing
details on their offerings.
[MUSIC PLAYING]